salut à tous ce petit être enregistrées
en post prod parce que j'étais trop
pressé d'aller pêcher alors à 2,8 pour
les trouvailles haïti a pas mal de
choses on n'est pas loin d'un pont et ça
aide
il
il ya un gros truc où résiste
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai encore quelque chose ouais c'est
quelque chose
quand un piqué au les cuillères
encore quelque chose
à
où
allez but c'est un gros truc là
c'est encore un gros truc je vais
essayer de le sortir sans tomber dans
l'eau ça va être un [ __ ] c'est une
barrière ou quoi on dirait
ouais
regardez moi ça
saloperie de barrières avait là les
mains tu ressors parce qu'ils sont pas
la barrière
une manière de plus sur la vie
il ya encore plein de trucs ici ça c'est
un gros spot tiger
non
ok
une autre barrière quand même non
ah ouais d'accord
ça se fait pas
vieux clous
voilà
heureusement très creuse hop là je t'ai
vu tu as essayé de retourner dans l'eau
ça marche pas comme ça avec moi toi ne
retournera pas je te garantis aux
[Musique]
pied de parasol
après que j'ai sorti ça il ya un gros
clous et envoya une cartouche 20 c'est
marrant ça tout aussi là dessus car dieu
est le deuxième un couteau ouais pareil
sérieux quoi mais françois c'est joli
tas sont des objets sympas voilà sur ce
on continue
oh un rubis c'est cool ça c'est plutôt
rare de broder rubis dans le canal
or et c'est du plastique mais c'est pas
mal
après j'ai trouvé une ville concept
alala jolie je vais la nettoyer je
prends
et une boucle de ceinture on va la
pulpeuse du saugeais devoir arrêter
parce que pour le trimballer après ça va
être compliqué en plus ça ira pour
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
alors là les gars ou à tous potes parce
que ce ne serait pas un aimant énorme
lorsque 6 1 méga watts
alors
qu'est ce que c'est que ça
plus un petit l'heure
premier dans deuxième lancer
mais regardez-moi st
tu sens
c'est vraiment un moment
c'est vraiment un aimant
ça attire mais bon
ouais un petit peu
c'est un immense bird il est énorme
regardez comparé à la taille de mon fils
il écrire
voilà on a déjà bloqué les sorties de
travail
rapporté un ami rôle soit on le
développe éléments le problème c'est
quand tu es seul
ça bouge pas
encore une grosse galère on a l'habitude
d'en faire un élément mais c'est quand
même toujours toujours très très 4 quand
tu te retrouves en plein milieu de
béziers que tu as un treuil et que le
treuil va tester t'accorde été obligé de
sortir la tenue de plongée j'ai pas
envie d'aller me baigner là mais bon
trois vaches non équipés
même pas
pas que
rappel shalimov parfaite
le sol
ouais mais du coup juste hors éléments
mais pourtant c'est à dire alors de
mettre votre honneur
c'est un bardage massue
[Musique]
pas retenu ses démarches
martyr mais pas venir qui parle des
divinités là
rien
donc là on se prend pour les trouvailles
j'ai trouvé ce machin on m'a par
ailleurs deux trains ou bus de toute
manière ça a l'air trop alors y'a aucun
souci
ouais c'est pas possible pas bien
dangereux
après j'ai fait
une douille et une clé
allez trouver au bon endroit on dirait
j'irai là bas
et le président important c'est de bien
ramener où j'ai remis pour fendre l'eau
l'important c'est de bien tirer du bord
qui a été refait
autrement il de la ferraille ou des
rochers ou je ne sais quoi
et là y'a il ya des trucs
des trucs
regardez ce que je vous disais propos
fort des douilles pour fait on garde du
jem et cassante entière talent est
abîmée
pour l'acheter
ce qui n arrange le canal du midi c'est
que
six sont interdites y veniez personne ne
s'y baigne c'est totalement dégueulasse
un aa
here we go
ouf art dv but
ça vient mais
pourquoi je sais pas
un gros truc là-bas
mais stop bien
ça a lâché pas
en cours
le marteau par morsure
c'est pas ça qui faisait ses vues
a gelé encore si les ventes et 1
jusqu'à ce jour
[ __ ] ça lâche
[Musique]
c'est génial mots
petit couteau pas mal pas mal on garde
hop si cette vidéo vous a plu n'hésitez
pas à lâcher un petit pouce bleus ça
fait toujours plaisir et à vous abonner
à la chaîne on se retrouve à bientôt
pour de nouvelles aventures carreau